Well, we got some big news to talk about.
We've got an update on the pandemic pink hair trend
that you all want to know about.
Last year, we saw the member light pink
and now the cut reports.
The pink is getting pinker.
This spring,
the pinks are coming in hotter and brighter.
Check out Naomi Osaka's pink look,
and then, Taraji P. Henson.
Look at Shakira.
Yes! - [Ross] Works!
Check out Maluma baby!
Yes!
Works!
Rate Jermaine Fowler.
But I want to know, would you ever do the pink hair?
You know, Ross, I've tried every hair color under the sun.
I understand more about hair
than I ever thought I could or would.
The one hanging Chad
of hair I would like to try is the pink trend.
Oh, you must! If you have to live your gem
in the hologram fantasy life, you know, and try it.
I, I couldn't pull it off.
I don't think.
Well, maybe we'll get wigs
and just take a, like a, a run at it.
Uh, okay. Next Drew's News.
Oh, actually!
Oh!
Well, no! There we are, Drew!
Oh, dear.
That's a really bold look, the blouse and the hair.
And I feel like, you know what though?
I feel like I look like I'm in a cool girl group.
You certainly look like the bass player.
Yeah! - [Ross] Yeah, which is a total compliment.
Oh, God! (Drew laughing)
No! (laughing)
Well, told 'ya, told 'ya, I couldn't pull it off.
Actually, I disagree Ross.
I think you look great.
And, thank you art department
and news team for, like, helping us see the light
and actually get to try it without damaging our hair.
All right.
Next, Ross, I want to talk to you about this.
I want to talk to you about cork.
Pardon?
That's right. Cork.
Okay. - Okay, I just learned
so much new stuff about cork,
and honestly, I've gone cuckoo for cork.
Are you ready?
All right.
We know it as the little plug that keeps your wine tasty
but Allure reports that court could be a secret weapon
in greening the beauty industry.
And this is important 'cause I am a beauty, a maker myself
and I'm always concerned
about the plastic and the recyclable and the PCR.
And 2018 alone,
7.9 billion
with a B, units of plastic were created
for beauty products, as well as personal care.
Okay. It's a very large category that was just
in the U.S.
But more companies are turning to cork packaging
because cork is biodegradable.
Okay.
It's harvested from live cork oak trees
with no harm done to the tree.
It's like it regenerates itself.
And the best news is harvesting cork
makes these trees actually regenerate themselves,
which is done through photosynthesis.
Say that with a list,
(Ross laughs)
Photosynthesis, which removes carbon dioxide from the air.
Wow! (audience applauding)
I mean, is that not the best corking news?
That you never corking heard?
(Ross laughing)
Listen, the best part about this.
Well, there's two things.
One, now, whenever I open a bottle of wine
I'm going to call it recycling.
Right?
And two, really that it regenerates itself is a game changer
'cause they can just take the bark off the tree.
And that's where they get the cork, you know?
And then it takes it like nine years to grow that back.
But the tree isn't harmed.
And they don't emit carbon into the atmosphere.
It's unbelievable.
And I think it's a game changer.
I mean, as somebody who's in business.
Is this something you're going to be looking into?
To sort of.
100% and I have to tell you in any of these industries,
it is so hard to create change
and it's going to take someone to do it successfully,
and then, everyone will follow.
So let's get this done.
Yeah.
Yes! Ms. Barry Moore has spoken.
Well, this story really spoke to me Ross,
and I'm very grateful to be bringing it to the news today
because The New Yorker magazine put out an article.
Email is making us miserable.
(Ross chuckles) Now, it's about some scientific proof
that your email inbox can cause burnout and anxiety.
They measured heart rate variability
and measure for mental stress and found a direct connection
between checking your email and rising stress levels.
People are trying to deal with it.
France has actually passed labor laws
to limit after work emails and companies
like Arianna Huffington
and Huff Po are creating new features
to fully delete emails that get sent to you
while you're on vacation.
And, I think it is all about pushing this re-evaluate button
because when something that you empty and conquer
just keeps filling up, filling up, filling up,
you can never escape the insurmountable task
of getting through your emails.
This is gonna to have an effect on us.
Well, and I know you are now
kicking it little house in the Prairie style.
You don't have an email anymore.
I got rid of it,
because if I heard one more people say,
"Didn't you get my email with a condescending look?"
like I was out of the loop
and dropping the ball in business or with personal stuff.
I went straight all to text
and it has improved my quality of life.
I don't know what would cause me more anxiety
like taking a break from my email
or not having access to my email.
I think we live in this world where like,
it just is the way it is.
Right. And I, I worry that I would worry
that I'd be missing out on something.
I'd had FOMO.
Do you have that at all?
Not having access to your email.
No, because now everybody's just texting me.
I don't know.
So, I don't feel like I'm missing out
but I do think this is the society we live in.
It's not going anywhere
but maybe we can re-evaluate our expectations
and approach to it.
Find that pretty little middle.
Okay, girl.
Maybe you convinced me just a little bit
to take an email chill pill just a little bit.
I'd also like you to help me find out how to unsubscribe
from J.Crew because they will not stop emailing me.
Thank you.
Well, look at you Rossie!
If I was J.Crew, I'd be emailing you too.
Oh, you're flirting.
She's flirting.
(lively music)